hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm if you keep up with
any chess news you may have recently
heard the name charissa if at 9 years
old she's become the youngest US chess
expert of all time chess expert being a
rating of 2000 or buff so I thought I'd
actually be interesting to go over one
of a recent game since again younger
players they just play with so much
passion many times at the Grandmaster
level you know at 20 moves they're just
playing for a draw
where younger players they make some
mistakes but it's really exciting chess
and some of these players are extremely
really strong in their game especially
Chris Yip who is already a chess expert
so this game actually comes a couple
months ago she took place in the online
championship and for the ages 10 and
below she actually won the event so I
thought it'd be really great since she's
gonna be a powerhouse in chess for many
years to come so go over one of her
games and so we take one of the feature
matches from that her opponent playing
white is Justin Paul around this time he
was around 1900 so a very very strong
player in his own right playing against
charissa who's gonna be defending with
the black pieces
Justin starts the game out with pawn to
d4 Carissa responds with Knight f6 and
then we have pond C for Pawnee 693 and
then the bishop coming down to before
now this is the nimzo-indian offense
very common for black to respond in this
way again pinning down the knight here
to the King White has a few options you
can go ahead and hold on to the bishop
pair and just allow charissa to go ahead
and take this knight on c3 and then have
doubled pawns on the C file another
option which Justin took is to bring his
Queen here to see - this is the
classical variation allowing black to
take the knight and white can recapture
with this Queen all those Queen is move
twice white doesn't have to deal with
the double pawns here on the C file so
that's kind of what Justin's going after
right now Chrissa decides instead of
taking with her Bishop here on a c3 so
go ahead and play pawn here to c5
because the Queen on you know d1 is
moved it's no longer protecting this
pawn here on d4 so it's gonna be kind of
a pain for Justin to hold on to this
pawn for a long time a lot of times in
this particular case you'll see the pawn
actually take here on c5 just because
white doesn't have to
doesn't want to have to deal with this
pawn and all the other pieces attacking
this pawn in this particular case white
played pawn here to e3 kind of
solidifying this pawn chain right here
and also opening up the door for this
LightSquared Bishop to defend this pawn
on c4
Chrissa decides to go ahead and take on
d4 and white recaptures with the pawn on
d4 and then the the pawns striking
forward to d5 now white could take right
now with his pawn here on d5 but really
no need to instead decides to go ahead
and develop more of his pieces towards
the center of the board kirsta has a few
options one of the stronger options
would be to go ahead and castle
there's no reason right away to go ahead
and give up this pawn right now it gives
white a very active position in the game
though black does decide to go ahead and
take this pawn on c4 giving up that
Center pawn here from D from from d5 and
white recaptures with his bishop here on
c4 so in this particular case white has
a very active position he has both of
his Knights in the center of the board
he has a bishop here on c4 just eyeing
down on the Kings side from black he
also has an aggressive Queen right here
on c2 which kind of opens the door for
him to really get involved into the game
also after the King castles he's gonna
be able to easily get his dark square
Bishop involved into the game attaches
rooks over here the only key weakness
that white really has right now is he
does have an isolated pawn right here on
the D file so it's very important that
black starts to put a lot of pressure on
this pawn on d4 and over time really
really weigh down all the pieces for
white to try to defend this wall black
kind of overwhelms white Chris and now
castles on the Kings side very nice
castling getting some King side safety
there and then white does the same thing
castles on the King side and then Krista
brings her knight over here to d7
Justin brings his Bishop up here to f4
and again I really has a very active
position both of his bishops dominating
the center of the board his Knights
dominating the stern of the board so
again it's really going to be can Justin
continue to dominate this urn of the
board and continue with his
very very aggressive play style now from
here Krishna decides to bring her knight
over here to be six attacking the bishop
here on c4 the bishop swings back here
to d3 less active position but again it
was being under attack right now and
then the pawn comes over here to h6 kind
of a prophylactic move stopping the
bishop from coming here to g5 the knight
coming over here to g5 kind of a waiting
move to see where White's really going
to go right now definitely make some
sense White has a few options if you
kind of look at it you could bring the
rook over here to e1 this is a semi-open
file you bring the rook over here to c1
this is an open file rooks definitely
belong on send me your open files where
they have a lot of room to breathe bring
it over here to see one makes a lot of
sense although there's some pieces right
now blocking it it's pretty easy to move
these pieces out of the way you could
play Queen here to b3 getting it out of
the way attacking this bishop as soon
the bishop moves you can now get your
knight involvement to the game and then
all of a sudden your rook is completely
dominating the C file and this bishop
here on c8 it really even hasn't hasn't
had a chance to move so those are some
of the options that White has Justin
decides to go ahead and play Knight here
to e2 somewhat of a passive move does
have a very aggressive position decides
to kind of bring his knight back here to
e2 and then black plays the knight here
to d5 more of a centralized square for
the knight again over here on b6 wasn't
doing too much but now I can really
start to dominate being here in the
center of the bull white now brings his
Bishop back here to g3 since it was
being attacked and then we have the
bishop swinging back here to these six
black looks like she's okay with
exchanging the bishops offs and that's
exactly what Justin does taking and the
Queen comes here to d6 again now a very
active square for this Queen here on d6
it can really get involved into the game
starting to put more pressure on whites
and now we have pawn here to a3 again
kind of one of those defensive moves it
does block off this b4 square so the
Queen can't come here to be for the
knight can't come here to be for
attacking both the Queen and the bishop
here so definitely a nice little waiting
move for
White's as he tries to see what blacks
going to do Curtis I christen decides to
go ahead and bring her Bishop here to d7
kind of opening the door for the bishop
to come here to c6 and then potentially
later on to d5 doesn't want to right
away bring her pawn out the door so
instead decides to kind of go the longer
route with her Bishop right here and
then we have the knight coming here to
e5 this is a nice little outpost always
be looking for the outpost this isolated
pawn although it doesn't have a lot of
defenses right now it does serve as a
nice little outpost so it's really gonna
be difficult since black doesn't have a
dark squared Bishop this is really gonna
be hard to chase away and so just to go
ahead Justin goes ahead and takes
control of this central square right
here any 5 and then Krista decides to go
ahead and play rook over here to c8
again controlling those open files are
you sensual and chess to get your rooks
really really involved now what's gonna
play over here Queen here to b3 again
trying to make sure that it's still an
active queen controlling somewhat of the
center of the board then we have the
bishop coming over here to c6 definitely
wants to make sure protecting this pawn
here on b7 also again more centralized
defending this night here on d5 now in
this particular case it's White's move
but we've pretty much reached equality
both sides have the same amount of
material but they also really have about
the same amount of material that's
actually in play that's actually doing
something so white maybe has a little
bit more of a lead as far as you know
his knight here has a nice little
outpost white does have an isolated pawn
right here all things equal though this
is pretty close to equality so it's
definitely interesting to see how both
sides go from this and actually start to
take an advantage one way or the other
Justin decides to go and bring his rook
over here to c1 again putting his rook
on the open file always a good idea and
then the knight comes over here to b6
what's gonna now play bishop here to b5
again wasn't doing much here on d3 and
this was a very active Bishop here on c6
so White's definitely okay with just
exchanging these bishops and having a
queen
here on b5 Chrissa decides she doesn't
want to have anything to do with that
and plays Bishop here to d5 nice central
square for the bishop it can pretty much
control the entire board and it's also
attacking the Queen here on b3 now the
Queen swings over here to e3 and
Christian actually missed a move right
now
and that is the bishop coming over here
to g2 now again even grandmasters make a
lot of mistakes sometimes it's very very
difficult to find the best move in all
particular cases especially when you are
sacrificing a pawn or excuse me a bishop
here on g2 but she did have the option
to take with her bishop here on g2 and
if the King recaptured with his King
right here then the Queen could come to
the five check and it would also be
forking the bishop here on b5 so that
was definitely a mistake from White's as
he played his Queen over here to e3
could have tried something even as Queen
over here - let's say g3 would have made
a lot of sense still protecting the
center of the board protecting that pawn
here on g2 definitely would have been
better instead Chrissa plays pawn to a6
which you know I have a weird sense of
humor but I think it's kind of funny
that the move that she does play pretty
much forces white to retreat the one
move that was in danger so this Bishop
here on b5 is forced forced to move to
come back to be three and now black can
no longer play this Bishop here - g2
because the bishop is safe black now
plays the Queen back here to b8 which I
find a little odd again
Chrissa had a very very great position
there was no threats to the Queen here
on D 6 and D 6 as you can probably
imagine is a much more threatening
position than back here on being it's
kind of tucked back here it's not doing
nearly as much and so it's definitely
interesting to see that the Queen come
back here to b8 with the position that
the carissa had now the pawns gonna push
forward to f4 which I really really like
from white because it if you kind of
look at the board stay from white it
says okay the Queen has now retreated
back
to the queenside there's kind of this
small little opening where okay there's
less pieces on the quick on the kingside
so I can start to go ahead and put a lot
of pressure on the kingside and kind of
overwhelm my opponent on the kingside so
f/4 I think is a really really strong
move and it kind of shows the creativity
that you know even kids under the age of
10 half because a lot of players are not
playing this f4 because they think it's
too aggressive or kind of opened up the
king but the King is really gonna be you
know in trouble if let's say black had a
dark square bishop that would be a
little more trouble for whites but as
soon as this Queen moved back over here
to the Queen side white and right away
attacked on the King side so black
decides to go ahead because of this to
go ahead and start to take up some of
that material bring it back over to the
Queen side and so the rook takes here on
c1 and then we have the rook retake here
on c1 Krista now responds with her rook
over here to c8 and then the rook comes
here to c5 would have been completely
fine if you know white treated off
you know rooks but you know that's okay
instead the Knights gonna come here to
a4 forcing the rook to move after the
work comes back now there's gonna be an
exchange now the bishop comes here to
see two attacking it would definitely be
a mistake for the night to come here
looking like there was potential
weakness on b2 free material but the
Queen could actually come to c3 and this
would be definitely bad for black as
black would end up losing this Knight
here
doesn't matter where they go it would
end up falling so definitely good on
charissa to see this free material on on
b2 and not take it instead decides to go
ahead and bring the knight back here to
b6 getting ready to do something else
with it because you definitely don't
want to leave your Knights on the rim
it's just not very active in the game so
the Queen's now coming kind of come over
here to c3 and then we have the bishop
coming here to e4 black is definitely
okay with having a very active knight in
the center of the board
and that's exactly what white allows
black to do so
after the the capture and the recapture
how black has a very active position
right here the Queen comes back here to
c2 and then we see Knight to d6 and
we'll go through a couple more moves we
have Queen here to c5 and then we have
the Queen coming over here to d8 which
again defends both of these nights here
on b6 and here on d6 which is nice but
again this queen is not nearly as you
know aggressive more involved in the
game as Chris would like definitely not
as involved as the Queen was earlier in
the game before she brought it back here
to b8 we kind of look from both sides
White's main goal is to keep the Queen
at bay make sure that Krista cannot get
that black Queen involved into the game
and really start to you know push and
put pressure on black now blacks goal is
gonna be a little bit different her goal
is gonna be to not only attack this
isolated pawn here on d4 but start to
get her queen involved into the game and
play less of a defensive game and start
to put white on the ropes as far as a
defensive position which right now
why does not white has all the momentum
in the world so those are it's kind of
both sides that's what both sides are
kind of thinking right now so white now
plays pawn here to b3 which stops kind
of the the movement to a4 to c4 which is
fine and now we have night here to to d5
I'm not even really sure that black we
really wanted to come to see for a4 but
again you know b3 stopped it right there
so we have d5 which is a nice little
centralized square for the knight and
then we have pawn here to g3 solidifying
this pawn chain doesn't have to worry
about protecting you know his pawns with
his minor pieces so this kind of
solidifies that and now Justin you know
should probably focus on you know
blocking out this Queen and then
starting even to get his King involved
into the game so now we have the knight
to e3 and then Chris is starting to play
much more aggressive and now the Queen
comes back to C 1 so again playing kind
of a defensive role and now the knight
comes back here to d5
and now the night comes back here to d3
instead of you know bringing the Queen
back into the action white started to
retreat back and plays the knight back
here to the three and Chrissa takes
advantage and plays Queen over here to
b6 kidding here Queen involved into the
game since White's kind of allowing her
to do that and then the knight comes
over here to c5 and the Queen comes here
to a5 attacking the pawn on a5 also
attacking the knight here on c5 and then
pawn here to b4 which is it kind of
looks okay because it's you know saying
hey you got to move somewhere but
Krishna doesn't mind just bringing her
Queen here to b5 attacking this night
here on e2 and really opening up the
door to get her queen past kind of this
fifth fourth rank right here and really
start to do with some damage and now the
Queen here on c1 from White's not doing
much and is playing much more of a
passive game just because of that one
subtle move or bring the knight back
instead of kind of blocking and and
forcing black to really not do anything
so from here we have the King coming
here to f2 kind of blocking the attack
on the night on e - now we have pond e6
our pawn beasts excuse me forcing the
knight to move so the knight moves and
then we have Knight to e4 great
centralized square for this night
attacking the King here on f2 after the
King comes here to e1 now we have the
Queen to d3 the queen is completely in
why it's business right now really
really hard for white to do much of
anything
Black's Keaney over here on g8 is just
completely hanging out it's kind of
interesting to see you know just six
moves ago black was kind of in this okay
what do I do state and now you know
seven eight moves later blacks in
complete control and so the Queen comes
over here to d1 and now the Queen swings
over here to f3 again there's not much y
can do you know it's gonna be checkmate
pretty soon the Queen swings back over
here to see one so that you know if the
Queen comes here to f2 which is exactly
what it does the King can swing
here to d1 but then after night here to
e3 Justin decides to go ahead and resign
because the only way to stop this is for
the Queen to actually take here on three
on III so phenomenal game really really
impressed by some of the youngsters in
the United States playing it's such a
high level of chess it's it's one thing
to do analysis of a game when you can
study it and kind of look at positions
from all different angles it's another
thing to actually play and just to see
the youngsters play such a high level of
chess is really really encouraging it's
always I even learned a lot just from
watching you know such great chess so
hopefully you guys enjoyed something
hopefully you enjoyed seeing some of the
younger generation play chess at a high
level and I will see y'all in the next
video thanks for watching